Use the points 0 comma 2,
2 comma 8, and x comma y,
on the blue line in the graph
below to complete the equation.
And they have this first
equation, y minus 2
over x is equal to blank.
And then they say
write the equation
of the line in the form
y equals mx plus b.
So we have a line here and
they give us two exact points,
and then they tell
us one general point
in terms of x comma y.
Although the way they've
drawn it on the diagram
it looks like it's the point
negative 3 comma negative 7,
but we'll assume
that we don't know
what those are, that those
are just two general points.
And what we want to do is
figure out what this ratio is.
And then we need to figure
out the equation of the line.
Well, a good place
to start is just
figure out the common ratio
between our change in y
and our change in x between
any two points in the line.
So let's think about that.
If I were to go from point 0
comma to 2, to point 2 comma 8,
what's going to
be my change in x?
So my change in x
is just like that.
is equal to-- well
to go from x equals
0 to x equals 2,
you had to go up two
in the x direction,
or you have to go to the
right two, I should say,
in the x direction.
And our change in y--
well, we're going from y
equals 2 to y equals 8.
So our change in y, if you're
going to go from 2 to 8,
your change in y--
remember triangle y,
this literally is the Greek
letter for delta, delta y,
is just a shorthand for
saying your change in y--
well I went from 2
to 8 is equal to 6.
So if you construct a
right triangle like this,
this side's length is 6,
this side's length is 2,
and the ratio of this
height to this base
is going to be the
slope of your line.
So delta y over delta x over
delta x is equal to 6 over 2,
which is equal to 3.
So what do we do with this?
How does this answer
either of those questions?
Well, this ratio, your change
in y-- your change in height--
versus your change in the
base right over here--
versus your change
in x-- is going
to be constant for any
right triangle constructed
this way on this line.
So for example, when you're
going-- this right over here,
y minus 2 over x.
Let's think about it
a little bit more.
If I were to go from the point
x comma y to the point right
here, which is the point 0 comma
2, what would my change in x
be?
So my change in x is going
to be equal to-- well
if I end up at x equals 0,
and I started at x, my change
in x is going to be 0 minus x.
And if that doesn't make a lot
of sense, just think about it.
If x is negative 3,
then our change in x
is 0 minus negative
3, which is 3.
The length of the side of the
triangle right over here is 3.
Now, let's think about the
height, our change in y.
Well, our change in y--
we end up at a y equals 2,
so it's going to be 2 minus
whatever our original y is.
And it looks like, if you
just eyeball it at this point,
it looks like it's
at about negative 7.
And if you have 2 minus
negative 7 you get 9,
and this indeed has length 9.
So this ratio, delta
y over delta x,
should be constant for any
right triangle constructed
like this where the
hypotenuse is the line itself.
So delta x over delta y-- or I
should say delta y over delta
x, the ratio of this
side to this side,
is always going to be the same.
These are all similar triangles.
It's going to have the same
ratio as this right over here.
So change in y is 2 minus y.
Change in x is 0 minus x.
This is going to
have the same ratio.
It's going to be 6 to
2, or 3 to 1, or just 3.
Now you're saying,
wait, Sal, that
still doesn't
answer my question.
Even if I get this
0 out of the way
I could write 2 minus y is
equal to negative x, or 2 minus
y over negative x is equal to 3.
But how does this get us to
this ratio right over here?
Well, if you multiply this
numerator and the denominator
by a negative sign-- so if you
just multiply the numerator
and the denominator
by a negative sign--
as long as you're doing
the same to the numerator
and denominator,
you're not changing
the value of this expression.
In the numerator
you'll get y minus 2,
and in the denominator negative
1 times negative x is x.
Well, that's still going
to be the same ratio.
That's still going to be 3.
So this right over
here is going to be 3.
And then they say write
the equation in the form y
equals mx plus b.
So when you have an equation
in the form y equals mx plus b,
this term right
over here, this is
that ratio we've
been dealing with.
This says, hey,
every time I increase
x by some amount how much
am I increasing y by?
This is your slope
here, and so we
know that this is going to
be of the form y is equal
to-- I want to do it
in that black color--
y is equal to our
slope, for this line is
3 is equal to 3x plus b.
And now we have to
figure out what b is.
And what helps us in
this is to recognize
that they've given
us several points.
They tell us what happens--
well, when x is 0, y is 2.
When x is 2, y is 8.
So we can use any one of
those points to solve for b.
I like using x
equals 0, y equals 2
because it cancels this
term out very nicely.
So we know that when x
is equal to 0, y is 2.
Or we could say when y is 2, or
when x is equal to 0, y is 2.
So 3 times 0 plus b is
going to be equal to 2.
Well, that's just a
0, and you're just
left with b is equal to
2, or 2 is equal to b.
So we're done.
It's y equals 3x plus 2.
So let's fill that in
on the actual exercise.
So this ratio is 3.
It's the ratio between a change
in height over our change in x,
that's constant,
across the line when
you construct a right triangle.
They're all going to
be similar they're, all
going to have that same ratio.
And then the equation of the
line, in that form, it's y
equals that change
in y over change
in x, that constant ratio.
Which is defined as
slope, 3x plus 2.
This 2, which is where
you intersect the y,
it is the value you
get when x equals 0.
That's often called the
y-intercept because, you see,
when x is equal to 0 that's
when you intersect the y-axis.
So y equals 3x plus
2, and you could
verify that any of these points
will satisfy this equation.
And we got it right.